- You need to understand
that I am a rapper.
So you know, usually I'm like,
"Here are the rules: don't
suggest shit suggestions."
I trust you, right?
You've come here 'cause I emailed you
and you were like, "We'd
love to come and see that,"
so you know that I don't
like shit suggestions.
Make 'em good.
Last night we had an abattoir
for gingers, we had...
(audience laughing)
First two rows, you're gonna
get suggestion number one.
What's it gonna be?
- [Audience Member] An
aspiring platypus estate agent.
- An aspiring platypus estate
agent, is that correct?
So, are we saying that the
estate agent is a platypus
or selling to platypuses
or platypoli or platypi?
Don't know-
- Platypus to platypus.
- Platypus to platypus. Okay, cool.
Great, cool.
(audience laughing)
Are they your favorite monotreme?
- Yeah, it wears hats.
- Yeah?
They wear- what? They wear hats.
- Yeah.
- Platypuses wear hats?
- Estate agent ones.
- That's how you can tell.
(audience laughing)
- That's fine! No.
They say it's legal in
Nevada, I don't know.
(audience laughing)
Platypus estate agent.
He's aspiring, hopes to be.
Let's come back to,
like, row three and four.
Who's got a suggestion from over there?
- [Audience Member]
Pizza boxes in Romania.
Romanian pizza-
- Oh, okay.
For those of you that don't know,
Andrew Tate is-
- [Voiceover] Allegedly.
- A rapist sex trafficker,
it turns out.
- [Voiceover] Allegedly.
- Why are you going, "See?"
- [Audience Member] He was
talking about him the other day
as if he was some great guy.
- No he's not, no.
(audience laughing)
No. He was on "Celebrity
Big Brother" in 2016,
he got thrown out because
he beat up a woman,
and then-
- [Audience Member] And Greta Thunberg-
- Yeah, which already, you're like,
"Why are you picking on
an autistic child," right?
(audience laughing)
He then, in the video, was, like,
showing her his nipple like a weird thing
and then he got arrested
by the Romanian authorities
by showing them the pizza box
and that proved he was in Romania,
they raided his house,
they took all his cars,
he's in jail because he's
a rapist sex trafficker.
- Allegedly.
- And somehow-
- This is all alleged.
- People are still like-
Exactly, so- well, I mean,
that goes with the rapist sex trafficking.
(audience laughing)
There's no, like,
"Well I rape and I sex traffic,
but I do put a coat down over
a puddle from time to time.
(audience laughing)
M'lady."
And then kick 'em.
(audience laughing)
Okay, no, he's a piece of shit.
Right, so the Romanian
pizza boxes, very good,
aspiring platypus estate agent.
Let's come to middle of the room.
What do you guys want a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Didn't
Happen of the Year Awards.
- The Didn't Happen of the Year Awards.
You are all so online, aren't you?
(audience laughing)
That's a Twitter account where they
kind of mock people who tweet things
and they say it didn't happen.
Did one win this year?
What was the one that won?
- [Audience Member] It was
a lady went into supermarket
and she was wearing
a "God Save the Queen"
T-shirt or something,
and the whole supermarket
burst into a chorus
of "God Save the Queen."
(audience laughing)
(Chris laughing)
- Yeah, that didn't happen.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Everyone clapped
apart from this young
lad who was on crutches
and he just stamped his crutch.
(audience laughing)
(Chris laughing)
- Further back in the
room, what have you got?
What do you want a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Mary
Berry at a sex party.
- Yeah, buddy!
(audience laughing)
Tell you what, I'm a big
fan of the Auburn lady and-
that's what I call Mary Berry.
(audience laughing)
When I lived in Oxford,
she was frequently at this farm restaurant
that was quite nearby and
I've seen her there twice
and she is fucking
smoking in person as well.
(audience laughing)
The camera adds 10 pounds.
She is, ooh, she's slender
and ready to bender.
(audience laughing)
(Chris laughing)
I'm so sorry. No one...
That is not a phrase, all right?
In case you're like, "Is
that a thing people say?"
That's a thing that I made up right now.
"She's slender and-" but it's-
'cause it's about Mary Berry
and I think as you age as a woman,
you stop being sexualized and I think,
you know, obviously you're
like, "Oh, finally,"
but also there must be a
little part of Mary Berry
that's like, "But I did also
used to fucking get it."
(audience laughing)
Mary Berry's hot, that's all I'm saying.
When she left, Prue Leith was back on
and I'm like, "No, not my type."
Mary, though, and she's at a sex party.
Okay, platypus estate agent,
pizza boxes in Romania,
the Mary Berry sex party, and
number three was, of course,
it was the Didn't Happen of
the Year Awards, of course.
And then fifth. Fifth
one! Make it the best one.
Don't make it something that's gonna
get me canceled again like that.
- [Audience Member] The
spare heir without a care.
- Despair-
- No, the spare.
- The spare.
- Heir.
- Oh! Harry, Prince Harry.
(audience laughing)
Good, very good.
The spare heir without a care.
He doesn't give a fuck, does he?
Why would you? Why would you?
He's livin' in L.A., he's livin' his life.
That's why he's smokin'.
Not as hot as Mary Berry, but who can be?
(audience laughing)
This is my thing now.
I fuckin'... Oh, who's over seventy?
Who's drawin' a state
pension? That's what I want.
(audience laughing)
Okay, we're gonna
do a rap about that. Rap
time, make some fuckin' noise.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(chill music)
Nice! Mm!
♪ Tyree's on the screen, nice tight rear ♪
♪ Purple sequins, Didn't
Happen of the Year ♪
♪ It's a clear winner
walkin' in the supermarket ♪
♪ Round applause, the
queen T-shirt I started ♪
♪ Applaudin' and cryin' from my eyes ♪
♪ A guy on the crutches
wobbles side to side ♪
♪ He can't touch his hands ♪
♪ Can't get his palms ♪
♪ And so he starts chair
dampin', that's the charm ♪
♪ If the queen passed
away and I was in Tesco ♪
♪ I'd be like, "Everybody,
come on, let's go!" ♪
♪ Start bowin' down like Salam Alaikum ♪
♪ And now King Charles, he'd be
comin' like the 'nother one ♪
♪ And on Twitter it won all of the votes ♪
♪ People say it didn't happen ♪
♪ They would vote and say yes ♪
♪ I'm gloatin'. Why? 'Cause I succeed ♪
♪ If I want to see a
little beast in the reeds ♪
♪ With a tiny little beak like a duck ♪
♪ I say, "What?" ♪
♪ This is fuckin' crazy,
I pick the prick up. ♪
♪ What are you doin'? Oh, we can discuss ♪
♪ I'm a real estate agent platypus ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪ I could see you bright shinin' ♪
♪ What's your job? ♪
♪ Well, I'm just aspiring ♪
♪ I don't really do ♪
♪ Do you want to buy this willow? ♪
♪ That's just a tree ♪
♪ I've listed it on Zillow and Zoopla ♪
♪ And all the other housing apps ♪
♪ Why's he lookin' smart? ♪
♪ 'Cause he wears a top hat ♪
♪ A very dapper guy walkin'
'round with his tail ♪
♪ Like a beaver that's tried
to be a bird but has failed ♪
♪ That's a monotreme ♪
♪ The other one, not kiddin' you ♪
♪ You've got the platypus,
then you've got the echidna ♪
♪ They're like a hedgehog ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm a rapper who could
talk about monotreme cloacas ♪
♪ That's the waste passage
they put out the egg ♪
♪ You're nodding like, "Very
wise words that you've said ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ That makes a lot of sense. ♪
♪ A clever little boy ♪
♪ I like him ♪
♪ Maybe I would employ him ♪
♪ Not in a lab ♪
♪ Well, it's a shame there ♪
♪ He could be flippin'
pizzas out in Romania" ♪
♪ You don't flip pizzas,
that's burgers, but fuck ♪
♪ I get the little box
and I package it up ♪
♪ I take it out to a mansion,
the dude won't wait ♪
♪ He's like, "Put it on my
plate! I'm Andrew Tate!" ♪
♪ He doesn't sound like that ♪
♪ He sounds fuckin' so inflated ♪
♪ He goes, "How long have
I waited? I want it ♪
♪ Yeah, oh, I like sexy foxes ♪
♪ I like bitches and pizza boxes ♪
♪ I put it open, oh shit ♪
♪ Now they're comin' in ♪
♪ Romanian police raiding my house" ♪
♪ Yeah, better than the rest ♪
♪ When you're out in Bucharest ♪
♪ People like Andrew Tate
put the prick to the test ♪
♪ A misogynist slightly like me ♪
♪ When I was ridin' out
hard on Mary Berry ♪
♪ I'm in the capitol of Romania ♪
♪ I walk into the basement, remain here ♪
♪ It's so dark, so dingy ♪
♪ The walls are so damp ♪
♪ I look around, I feel
just like a champ ♪
♪ I've got my chain, got my
whips, got all of my latex ♪
♪ I see over here Victoria sponge ♪
♪ Who made it? ♪
♪ I look to my left and
I plunge my finger ♪
♪ My gosh, how airy is this sponge? ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ With all the whipped cream ♪
♪ All the nice jam ♪
♪ All the caster sugar on the top ♪
♪ My plan goes out the window ♪
♪ I get erect, y'all ♪
♪ Because I see the woman who
be settin' that technical ♪
♪ From the bake off ♪ ♪
I take off my clothes ♪
♪ Mary Berry's like,
"You've been a bad boy ♪
♪ You chose to do this ♪
♪ Come to me, Chris" ♪
♪ She leans in, gives me
the tiniest of kisses ♪
♪ Then she runs away,
she's playin' hard to get ♪
♪ Mary Berry yeah, she
ain't a fuckin' sketch ♪
♪ She's the hottest lady on the BBC ♪
♪ Although she's not been on
it recently, but that's fine ♪
♪ Who's that there in the air
killing Taliban soldiers? ♪
♪ The heir without a
care, he's the spare ♪
♪ 25 chess piece off the board ♪
♪ Really? Harry, are
you really quite sure ♪
♪ That you want to equate
human life to chess pieces? ♪
♪ He says, "I don't care if it moves ♪
♪ If I see it, I'll gun it down ♪
♪ I do it for the military" ♪
♪ This is less funny than Mary Berry ♪
♪ So we'll go back there in the dungeon ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ Oh, Mary, come on, yeah ♪
♪ I start plungin', I want a fun W.A.P. ♪
♪ She takes the the
whips and she spanks me ♪
♪ And Paul Hollywood's
there and he thanks me ♪
♪ I say, "No, I'm gonna
take this Mary Berry dildo ♪
♪ I don't want a handshake from you ♪
♪ You're a loser" ♪
♪ And I say, "Wow, I like Mary Berry ♪
♪ Fuck Paul, he's a fuckin' Scouse" ♪
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)